foreign
comes from Carter in Washington he says
I'm dealing with a tricky situation and
I don't know how to approach it I'm 21
years old and in my first year of
working for Boeing the income system
works where I start at twenty dollars an
hour and at the six year mark I will
shoot up to 42 dollars an hour the
problem is my father who essentially
runs a factory for Boeing and can get me
straight into the management starting at
sixty dollars an hour but he thinks that
this is ill-advised because I don't know
my business yet and haven't built a
foundation through Boeing it I feel like
if I become a manager now my projected
future could be so much better
financially management is salary so you
can be laid off whereas my current job
is union he wants me to max out the
Union first then shoot to management so
if I get laid off I can go back to a
maxed out union job how do I navigate
this oh Carter
slow down young grasshopper that's the
gist of my advice I mean it's like me
saying you know I'd like to um I'd like
to make 10 million dollars now Jade well
because it will allow me to do so many
more things right now Jade yeah I want
10 million dollars now well you know
what I wanted to be able to dunk a
basketball all right I wanted to play
pro basketball well
I'm five foot eight and can't jump over
paper all right so we have some issues
there so the idea here is is while I'm
limited in my height and athletic uh and
vertical leap ability vertically
challenged yeah I employ in more than
one way uh with the height and the
ability to jump uh and quite frankly it
couldn't hit the three under pressure
but die digress the point is is that
you're young you're starting out your
first year make it twenty dollars an
hour bro that ain't bad dude are you
kidding me that ain't bad that's great
money my first job was 515 an hour come
on
I'm the old guy 425 an hour oh yeah in a
greenhouse in Virginia in the summer
holy moly and I was so little back then
I had to run around in the shower to get
wet yeah I didn't have much fluid to
lose and you're sweating like it was
crazy it was horrible
um my friend your dad's right don't
pressure your dad I hope your dad has
the Constitution to say no to you to say
slow down son yeah uh so here's the deal
you need to earn it and and you set it
in your in your question
um I just don't have a foundation and
you don't you don't have any experience
and you have limited skill so pay it now
pay it now pay your dues pay it now and
then the next will take care of itself
so that's that's uh the extent of my
advice there Jade anything you want to
add to that I mean you you were a very
successful Entertainer before you got
here you know what it's like to pay your
dues you got to pay your dues you know
if you if you try to Sprint and Source
straight to the top you're going to run
into so many situations that you haven't
learned how to handle yet and in the end
you could end up falling on your face
it's way better to just like you said
pay your dues and because you learn so
much as you go and you cannot skirt that
process don't don't try to skirt it